divide and express as a simplified
rational state the domain so we start
off with this expression we actually
have one rational expression divided by
another rational expression and like
we've seen multiple times before these
rational expressions aren't defined when
the denominators are equal to zero so P
plus 5 cannot be equal to 0 if we
subtract both sides of this of this I
guess we can't call it equation we could
call it the not equation by negative 5
we subtract negative 5 from both sides
you get P cannot be equal to these
cancel out negative 5 that's what that
tells us and over here we could do the
same exercise for P plus 20 also cannot
be equal to 0 if it was this expression
would be undefined subtract 20 from both
sides for P cannot be equal to negative
20 divide both sides by 4 P cannot be
equal to negative 5 so in both
situations P being equal to negative 5
would make either of these expressions
either of these rational expressions
undefined so the domain here the domain
is the domain is all we could say the
set of all reals such or PP is equal to
the set of all reals such that P does
not equal negative 5 or essentially all
numbers except for negative 5 all real
numbers so we've stated the domain now
let's actually simplify this expression
so when you divide by a fraction or a
rational expression that's the same
thing as multiplying by the inverse so
let me just rewrite this thing over here
so 2p plus 6 over P plus 5 divided by 10
over 4p plus 20 is the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal here
multiplying by 4p plus 20 over 10 I
change the division into a
multiplication and I flipped this guy
right here now this is going to be equal
to 2p plus 6 times 4p plus 20 in the
numerator and although I won't skip too
many steps let me just write that 2p
plus 6 times 4p plus 20
in the numerator and then P plus five
times ten in the denominator now in
order to see if we can simplify this we
need to completely factor all of the
terms in the numerator in the
denominator and in the numerator 2p plus
six we can factor out a two so the 2p
plus six 2p plus six we can rewrite it
as two times P plus three and then the
four P plus twenty we can rewrite that
we can factor out a four as so times
four four times P plus five and then we
have our P plus five down there in the
denominator we have this P plus five we
can just write it down in the
denominator P plus five and then even
ten we can factor that further until we
can into its prime components or in its
prime factorization we can factor ten
and factor ten in two times two times
five that's the same thing as ten now
let's see what we can simplify and of
course this whole time we have to add
the caveat that P cannot equal negative
5 we have to add this restriction on the
domain in order for it to be the same
expression as the one we started off
with now what can we cancel out we have
a 2 divided by a 2 those cancel out we
have a P plus 5 divided by P plus 5 we
know that people's 5 isn't going to be
equal to 0 because of this constraint so
we can cancel those out so what are we
left with
in the numerator we have 4 times P plus
3 times P plus 3 and in the denominator
all we have is that green 5 all we have
is that 5 and we're done we could write
this as 4/5 times P plus 3 or just the
way we did it right there but we don't
want to forget we have to add the
constraint P cannot be equal to negative
5 so that this thing is mathematically
equivalent to this thing right here